اهلا بكم من قناه الجزيره في قطر تعهد
قاده مجموعه الدول السبعه الصناعيه الكبرى
لتزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه وقدرات للدفاع
الجويه
في اجتماع عبر تقنيه الفيديو بمشاركه
الرئيس الاوكراني امكانيه فرض عقوبات اكثر
صرامه على روسيا وتقديم مزيد من الدعم
الخارجيه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي في اجتماع
لهم على تخصيص اكثر من مليارات يورو دعمك
الخارجيه في الاتحاد
ان خلافات حاله
التاسعه من العقوبات على روسيا
ميدانيه في اوكرانيا تواصل القصف الروسي
والشرقيه اوكرانيا وجنوبها كما افادت
مراسله الجزيره بان القصف الصاروخيه
الاوكرانيه تجدد على وسط مدينه دانيت
شيع اهالي مدينه جنين الفتاه جانا زكارنه
التي استشهدت امس برصاص الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه واوضحت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه ان الفتاه اصيبت برصاصه في
الراس اطلقها الجنود الاحتلال خلال
اقتحامهم منطقه البيادر بمدينه جنين قد
اقر جيش الاحتلال قتل الفتاه ذكرنا دائما
عن طريق الخطا
من جانبه اعرب وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي عن
اسفه لمقتل جنازه كارنا قال ان تحقيقا قد
فتح للوقوف على ملابسات ما جرى
اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيليه 14
مواطنا فلسطينيا في انحاء مختلفه من الضفه
الغربيه ليله الماضيه وفجر اليوم واشار
نادي الاسير الفلسطيني لان الاعتقالات
تركزت بشكل خاص في مناطق بيت لحم ورام
الله وجنين
حمل اتحاد الشغل في تونس رئيس الجمهوريه
نتائج ما سماها سياسه التعنت والانسداد
وحذر الحكومه من الاستمرار في ما وصفها
بالسياسه لارتجال وانعدام الكفاءه في
مجابهه الاسماء وقال الامين العام للاتحاد
نور الدين الطبوبي من البلاد تعيشون عرج
خطيرا وضع الرئيس للقيام بخطوات الى
الوراء من اجل الوحده الوطنيه
بعقد تحالفات مع الخارج وبالسعي وراء
السلطه و بعدم المبالات بمطالب التونسيه
اتفقنا التوتر في شمالك صفوف بين الاقليه
الصربيه والسلطات عقبات تبادل لاطلاق
النار مع الشرطه الاقليم بعد اعتقال
الشوطين صربيا سابق وحضر الاتحاد الاوروبي
من اين هجمات محتمله على البعثه الاوروبيه
كما حضرت الرئاسه الروسيه من مواجهه
مفتوحه واتهامت الدول الاوروبيه والولايات
المتحده بالتواضع وحملتهم مسؤوليه التدهور
الامني في المقابل دعت واشنطن الى ضبط
النفس واتخاذ اجراءات فوريه لتهدئه الموقف
والانتناع عن الاعمال الاستفزازي
انت هالموجز الى اللقاء